okay so just six months ago cloud9
announced that they'd be putting
together
a so-called colossus of a counter-strike
roster with the help of former
commentator henry g
world-class coach cassad and a boatload
of cash
they set out to build the biggest
baddest squad in the whole of cs go
so why is it that less than a week ago
they announced that they'd be
leaving cs entirely
[Music]
okay guys so as you may have noticed we
are still well on our way to two
million subs and one of the things
that's gonna help us get there is if you
guys hit that subscribe button make sure
to also
like the video turn on that notification
bell so you never miss it when we upload
new content
and let me know in the comments if you
guys want to see other counter-strike
related donatos just like this one
okay so for those who don't know cloud9
actually have a
long storied and kind of spotty history
in cs go
why do i say that well despite having
been in the game since
pretty much the beginning they've always
had a tendency to be
kind of cheap after their inaugural 2014
roster fell through which consisted of
such beauties as
shroud nothing sean garris and hiko
cloud9 kinda did this thing where they
recognized nacs to be a
total [ __ ] show and consequently became
kind of stingy when assembling their
rosters
now to be clear that is not a knock
against either cloud9 or their players
they had an
eye for up-and-coming talent they just
weren't interested in spending huge
amounts of cash on
world-class lineups like phase or g2
and watching as these so-called super
teams
never quite lived up to expectations
instead they'd take
chances on unproven up-and-comers like
stewie and automatic
place them under the leadership of tried
and tested veterans and
pray that they'd perform if they did
great
they looked like geniuses if they didn't
they never risked much to begin with now
for years
this netted cloud9 some iconically coin
flippy performances
sometimes they'd punch well above their
weight other times
not so much it just so happens that one
of the few
big international tournaments where
everything did come together for c9
was a major cannot miss a single shot
guardian waits patiently as cloud9 sets
the push up
oh oh it's happened they made it work
clown nine are your alien major
champions
[Applause]
jokingly referred to as the flukiest
major win of all time
c9's victorious run at the eleague
boston major in january of 2018
marked the moment at which their
infamously frugal framework
paid off in the biggest way imaginable
the issue of course is that it didn't
last a lack of stability led to skedaddy
retiring while stewie and terex set sail
for brazil
needless to say the roster kind of
imploded after that
they tried some stuff with fns golden
and flusha but
thanks to some very expensive buyouts
serious health issues and
family related deaths none of it ended
up working out
c9 were dealt bad hand after bad hand
and suffered a tragedy after tragedy
until finally they had nothing left so
in typical
cloud9 fashion come 2020 they took yet
another gamble on yet another group of
unproven up-and-comers this time a squad
of american and south african players
known as oc
jt floppy motm and sonic
who'd been aching to make their mark and
they did
kind of i don't know if sonny's gonna be
able to do anything here but here's the
peek from floppy
sprays down two gets into that 1v2
situation he's got to be careful there's
about behind but he finds that kill as
well
leaves epics all on his own clutch
master
to finish it off and may actually just
go for the diffuser he spots him a
little bit further away just trying to
bait him in doesn't have a kenny fight
to kill as well
what a sick play coming out from floppy
despite being
super promising prospects coveted pretty
much
ripped north american counter-strike
apart with everything being moved online
and all of the biggest events taking
place in europe
it became extremely hard to justify
housing a lineup
anywhere else so unfortunately they had
no choice but to drop the roster
now the crazy thing is that they didn't
take a break from cs the way a lot of
people thought they might
on the contrary they took the fight to
europe and
doubled down harder than ever before
how well by bringing on
henry g knife what are you doing steel
is that worth it is that worth it at all
what an absolute idiot
that's right in september of last year
it was announced that jack etienne the
cloud9 ceo
had brought on counter-strike's
smoothest most sultry voiced
sportscaster
to be the general manager of their brand
new no expense spared csgo roster
known as the colossus things became
especially hype when it was
simultaneously announced
that henry's first acquisition was that
of alexander kassad
trifunovic the world-renowned coach
who'd helped spearhead renegades
and later hudder thieves to success
here's henry g
talking about the move on the hltv
confirmed podcast back in september
i'm the first piece of the puzzle i
bring in the coach as well
and then we're building the team
together which with logic and kind of
an understanding of the industry instead
of just trying to squeeze it all
together throw money
and hope we can get attracting big names
we're taking our time might not seem
like it we've been working on this for a
while
now from the get-go the understanding
was that cloud9 weren't just out to do
well in the space but flat-out dominated
this became very clear when it was made
public that they'd started
by signing former vitality in-game
leader alex
to a whopping 1.65 million dollar
contract
and it didn't end there messi gamer
legion's hidden talent
fetched half a million floppy who they
chose to retain from the old c9
also half a million but mouse's former
opera mr 2400 edpi himself
waczyk 1.3 million better yet
astralis former substitute essetag tag
2.1 million now i know what you're
thinking
colossus with this lineup
really at the time when these
announcements were being made
a lot of us expected to see names like
smooya maybe
nico instead we got a roster that
didn't feel a whole lot like a super
team and
as it turns out they didn't play like
one either
and they're going to be as well they
beat the call and they've lost all of
their health
all of their players a catastrophe for
clown nine
still it came as a shock when after just
three months of subpar results
their fabled coach kassad up and left
the squad in order to rejoin his old
australian comrades on extremum
since apparently he'd been clashing
heads with alex
what's even crazier is that about two
weeks later they parted ways with
waksick who hadn't been playing well on
account of issues relating to ping and
time zone now they were able to replace
him with former chaos rifler zeppa
which was super exciting for fans of
nacs
since zeppa is a god but virtually
everyone in the community was left
wondering
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
roster well as it turns
out not a whole lot in the three months
that followed cloud9 lost
pretty much everything there is to lose
not only were these guys not living up
to the multi-million dollar hashtag
colossus name
they were failing to beat tier 2 teams
at tier 2 events
[Laughter]
needless to say it was both very
shocking and
somehow not much of a surprise when it
came to light late last week that after
only
half a year cloud9 would be scrapping
the colossus project in addition to the
fact that the squad had failed to
qualify for the playoffs of esl pro
league season 13
kovit had endured longer in europe that
c9 had initially expected
and according to a report from ryan at
rushby media
was adding quote undue stress to the org
and its players
however according to said report jack
was also
adamantly clear that his org's departure
from cs go
would not be permanent and that they'd
be looking to return
after covet had subsided and slapped
together
an actual north american roster and as
much as it
saddens me to say it i don't really
think anyone can blame him this was an
extremely
costly endeavor for cloud9 and dare i
say one of
the biggest financial failures in the
history of counter-strike
cloud9 took a very very big chance
and it really didn't pan out now as for
how it's going to shake out for all the
parties involved
we're still not 100 sure henry's twitter
account has been radio silent since the
announcement came out though according
to rushby media's report
he's still under contract with c9 and a
quote
incredible professional and someone who
jack would like to work with in the
future
unsurprisingly the players themselves
have yet to reveal
anything concrete about their futures
though according to a report by nell
some of them are already entertaining
the prospect of switching to valorant
quote maybe even directly with cloud9
okay hear me out because i've got a
valor and conspiracy theory
c9 keep tens they transfer zeppa from
their cs roster to their valorman one so
as to reunite him with leaf
they transfer katie from c9 white to the
other lineup
and they sign vanity from version one as
their new igl
that way chaos esports club lives on
in more than just our hearts now
unfortunately for cloud 9 it seems
very unlikely that they'll be able to
recoup the funds they spent on these
players vis-a-vis buy-outs
since well it was a very costly failure
in fact according to ryan's report
cloud9 aren't intent on seeing a return
and have allowed the players to search
for quote
new homes while benched and look while
all of this does look pretty
doom and gloom right now the upside of
all of this
is that cloud9's eventual return to cs
in a post-covet world
could be exactly what the north american
scene needs to
jumpstart back to life because leaving
aside all the memes and doomsday
prophecies
nacs isn't actually dead
it's just comatose and one day hopefully
soon
cloud9 could be the ones to spring it
back to life
but until that happens for the first
time in a long time
cs go will just have to forgo the blue
and white
if only for a little while what what is
the dog that
screams to meet you my girlfriend tells
me all the time that i just am a golden
retriever
like just i just spiritually
you know psychically psychologically
yeah
okay i'm a golden retriever